hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to live now we just
flipped a switch that did power and I
was under the assumption that it was
gonna turn these on but oddly enough no
I can't just wander out the door that
says exit that would make everything too
easy and then the game would be over and
then we wouldn't be threatened almost
dying so we got to find another way to
go over here I bet I know what it did it
turned off the fan oh if I would have
just looked to the left I would have
noticed that but I'm an idiot and I
don't actually look at my environment so
now I can go through here and not get
diced up into little itty-bitty pieces
and I can progress this way okay so
where does this lead if not away from
the exit oh my god that's cool that
looks really nice am i go about to go
for a ride
Oh
better keep me safe
with this piece of one come from
oh geez
goddamnit how much blunt-force trama
this poor guy gonna experience what kind
of madness governs this place I have
seen it heard strange things in my life
but it all pales in comparison who was
that man whatever it is must be losing
my mind or maybe there be monsters in
here I don't know which would be which
but you've gone through a lot you have
hit your head quite a lot like I
wouldn't be surprised if on the way down
you just hello
oh I'm coming too oh yeah I did suffer a
concussion boy I wish I could see
something oh oh maybe a little bit hello
ah that ain't good what's with all the
hanging bodies
there really couldn't have been that
many people down here good their method
maybe I don't know
come on snap to it
mister dawn Robert this is named Rob Oh
Bravo Oh No you've now been infested by
the mushrooms
what the hell
[Music]
Hey
Oh
[Music]
oh wow that that's honestly uh-huh I did
not expect that I in no way expected
that why why do I get magical powers I
mean it's kind of Awesome but I'm I'm
super confused here can I pull these
body bags towards me
probably not hey that guy did I land on
you probably I steal your power and some
weird transference it did okay then I
guess super I guess we just have this
power then well good thing we came down
here huh alrighty then it just went all
Bioshock all of a sudden wish I'm not
opposed to love me somebody
excuse you anyway I definitely love me
some bio chakras it's a little confusing
Oh
ooh can I yeah cool I don't think it's
gonna protect me from any of the
monsters unless I use my powers to boost
him all over the place man if someone
gives me a chair after all this they're
gonna get a chef so far up their butt
with super powers ah lots of objects
seem to be in my way well too bad
oh no I don't need to ever use my hands
for doors again boink
get out of my way I'm all-powerful now
maybe I could here
Oh Oh energy supplements once you're out
of energy your abilities will start to
drain your health instead ah so I can't
just well no no get that back here get
that back here I need that it didn't use
it okay so now that I have that and I
forget what button it wanted me to do
that with but hmm
okay all right I'll keep these with me
that is super weird but kind of cool the
resonator one due to recent incidents
the staff has come up with various plans
containing countermeasures for the
increasingly large number of people
struck by the affliction preliminary
progress has already been made in the
development of the very first prototype
of a resonance type device its primary
function will be that of a failsafe
device to secure the facilities and keep
the staff safe from harm from what what
is exactly the affliction that's what's
confusing here is the affliction like
something where some people are affected
positively with it and some people are
affected negatively by it
maybe I've been able to extract another
substance from the black liquid and
unlike the previous this particular
fluid radiates in a brilliant blue color
the rats I was able to catch him proving
useful for more than a few reasons I've
let my imagine why 'old but for whatever
I do to them the restorative tincture
seems to keep them alive
oh you're murder imagination the the
MIRR dementia nation okay so what am I
supposed to do here I miss put something
here yeah I got that oh it revealed it
revealed them what did that do
ah yes okay that's probably good I
really hope that this power doesn't like
make me powerful against monsters or
something because I I'm hoping it's
exclusively for puzzle-solving because
that would be pretty darn amazing
because I don't need it to battle
monsters I don't
battle monsters anyway get out of get
out of my way get out me ray okay
because when it comes to monsters I
wanted to remain pure that I'm
completely powerless against them which
i think is a great mechanic in Horgan's
in general where's this lady hi is key
oh okay
God those good for me this a no excuse
me it's still very dark oh it's so dark
is that okay
oh it's yellow liquid okay so is that
gonna be another element in this entire
endeavor because the yellow liquid seems
to be powering a lot of things it was
powering the elevators so it must be
their energy source in my studies of the
black liquid I've discovered I'm able to
refine part of the substance by no means
should this be considered a complete set
of instructions but rather a simplified
explanation I started out by heating the
substance and then filter out the
clumped residue and then finally after
the purification of the resulting fluid
I treat it with a varied amalgamation of
acidic compounds curiously the resulting
characteristics differ wildly depending
on the mixture used this will definitely
require some further experimentation so
this must be some of the refinement that
he's doing here huh oh sorry it didn't
mean to do that
ooh danger corrosive material where oh
it's a wall I couldn't even tell that it
was a wall damn it sir like a lever or
something no lights no lights I push
this one no that was not good okay oh
maybe I was supposed to pick this up and
fill it up ooh that would make sense
maybe hello basky Oh Fran juillet I
don't know what that means my supposed
to be a liberal break the tie here we go
hello what is this - nope No No Oh oh
that primer stores my blue cool another
day of no one listening to me at all the
resonator to the resonance type devices
is designed to act as both a sensor and
a deterrent the first part of the sensor
is a simple variable-pitch electronic
oscillator embedded into an in contact
with the metal hull attacked as an
antenna with the other part being a
standard frequency oscillator under
normal circumstances the oscillator
frequencies will match and the device
will remain idle but once the increased
cell density and interference from an
afflicted patient enters the magnetic
field however the oscillators will be
out of tune when this occurs the device
will trigger the three steel discs
embedded inside they will start rotating
in close proximity permeating the
area with a high-pitched vibration that
will only affect the afflicted the
vibration causes them great discomfort
and makes increasingly disoriented
quickly driving them away okay so am I
supposed to use that as a deterrent
against the horrible monstrosity 'z that
are after me correct at least that's my
understanding of what's going on here I
don't have a resonator to be said I
don't know where the resonator is and I
can't exactly go down this hallway
because it's blocked off oh ah here we
go okay so it's a puzzle
it's a puzzle and I know how to puzzle
it point hooray yay
whatever the weird yellow goop that's
what I was supposed to do and hopefully
this works now yes Oh finally a goddamn
door that works I've been surrounded by
all that broke machinery now I actually
have been having a dick oh well this is
a big underground cavern with more
bodies
Jesus why so many bodies I'm starting to
piece together that they were running
some kind of like operation not an
operation like there was running some
kind of an experimentation business and
they found a substance and they were
trying to build something around old
that's all well and good hi I just
imagine that they weren't exactly
telling the workers that were down here
what they were supposed to be doing Oh
am I supposed to I think I'm supposed to
use these as like a staircase or a
stepping stone to get across the black
goop
I'm running out of coupie and I don't
exactly know
Boop Gill cube yep way okay
[ __ ] I don't have more stuff that'll be
enough now ow okay fine then we'll take
some damage
Oh up arrow good thank you to happen I
don't think that's gonna help me thank
you though
appreciate the offer oh god damn it
oh come on get back here don't you run
away from me the big box Larry there's
no tie about Tim around there you and me
Larry
yep no I mean
it good
lovey enough whoop-whoop huh huh okay so
now we're thank you cuz they even
supposed to go this way I think so
because I was gonna give me the thing
that needed to get so what was the
button for goopy ah are okay hello hi
hello there's something good get out of
my way
get off me way thank you right moving on
hello I am pleased to see that the
costly machinery is still operational in
spite of recent events undoubtedly it
will not take long before everything
will break down and leave me in the dark
but I am positive I will have a solution
to some of these annoyances before this
happens signed dr. Rosenberg so you were
just left down here alone after everyone
was dying around you and these people
became afflicted and you just kind of
went with it and it's a mere annoyance
to you that all these humans started
going crazy probably okay so what am I
supposed to in here
maybe I wasn't supposed to go that way
just yet okay ah by Odin's beard once
again I have no idea war
is that the resonator Oh oh my god hi
that looks so cool that's so cool what
with your flaming eyes dear Odin sir oh
is that the resin I believe that's the
resonator but it doesn't seem to be
affecting me which is probably a good
thing because hopefully I'm not affected
just yet
whoa that's cool that's so cool okay so
that's neat oh I'm doing a good job of
finding all the secret places hi
is that God it's so dark I can't see
goddamn squat
weird vibrating device did that do
something I don't know what that did
what the shaking stops oh that was good
okay so if I go back am I gonna find
something else is this oh no there was
other avenues in Odin's room okay barrel
stop following me you son of a [ __ ] hey
it hurts it hurts I don't think I'm
supposed to open that because I kind of
want that running because I'm assuming
that that's gonna be something that I
need for the monsters they're giving me
so many ways to stop the monsters and
yet I haven't seen them why oh god
another one over there okay so I'm
guessing I need to shut hey just want to
make sure you were actually dead I hate
it when I'm wandering around and things
that I assume are dead come up and get
me
ah ok ok ah there we go
ha doesn't easy puzzle easy peace
nothing to it
ok so what did that do ok now that one's
done but what were they powering is a
question must have been maybe it was
Odin maybe they were powering Odin he's
old and done ok I I said that I didn't
want that thing to be stopped
[Applause]
oh jesus oh jesus oh jeez
hey I'll fight you [ __ ] hey I'll shove
this straight up your butthole if you
even have one ass right you better run
away oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] hear that
roar you're a fight bro come on come on
angry oh man that's funny
will you stop by a bar
oh [ __ ] you bruh oh geez that hurt him
that got him guarded okay running
running running hey ain't too bad
too bad [ __ ] [ __ ] where do we go [ __ ]
give me back holy [ __ ] balls okay okay
what do i do what do i watch ease oh
jeez vada Danny okay go this way now red
light a glowing that ain't good
that's how I'm supposed to be oh I
[ __ ] up I'm out of stamina oh I [ __ ]
it oh I [ __ ] it
I have [ __ ] it was that is this is
this an explody this fragile a I should
blast this on his ass hey come here I
got an ass blast for you right here
holy [ __ ] why are you broken I'm gonna
take this whose food [ __ ] oh god he
broke all that [ __ ] [ __ ] he's much more
unstoppable than I thought he was I'm
[ __ ]
they'll never find me I'm creeping
behind boxes there's no way don't do it
bro don't do it like I've said many
times before I'm a wild animal when I'm
cornered I'll scream in your face and
it'll hurt your ears and then you go
crying to mommy oh wait no that's me
this is out the time
he forgot I was here too what an idiot
what a loser okay
we might be standing right there
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] oh where do I go oh
Jesus Jesus Jesus only crap balls I
didn't even know where he was
what are we supposed to do I can't do
anything
God why did I stop this [ __ ] thing
walk man I'm an idiot
I'm a goddamn I can't run him out of
Stan
[Music]
okay geez huh man come on dude dude dude
man dude man okay so good golly
how's the thing man
please vining no more than markiplier
he's such a slippery [ __ ]
oh you heard my buddy nerve okay so did
he go away I don't know that might have
been the disappointed Huff of him being
done but let's not be too testy here I
mean I don't want to go hiding in a
corner forever and ever but I want to
know okay so obviously this is where oh
there was a switch watch I wasn't too
much of a panic to even notice that oh
and it's slow too
so obviously I would have been running
around in a circle waiting for the gun
thank you for that was very useful I
appreciate that very much
okay well we finally got to have a good
old meeting with the monster that was
more terrifying than I thought it'd be
he was um persistent I thought he was
goofy because he was flipping that box
over I thought he'd be stopped by that
but apparently uh Early's faster and
smarter than I thought he was then I
gave him credit spews me she used me
um excuse me you guys hiding a secret
over here okay it's a simple elevator
door ah good this looks comforting so
what was the point of that run was there
anything in there
um I'm not I'm not too keen on being
completionist about this and what does
CR stand for anyway I have no idea oh oh
it's already here okay nope I must have
missed the last note somewhere probably
in that back room over there okay for
that fine that's fine I'm not too
worried about it's okay
wonder if this is gonna crash on me too
I wonder if I'm gonna get another
concussion what is happening to me I can
move objects without touching them when
I approach this device it suddenly
reacted to my presence as if it had an
awareness of its own it's just what
happened to everybody did they lose
their minds yeah probably I'm a hundred
percent sure that's what it is and
you're actually affected or afflicted
which means that you're infected with
whatever the hell is killing everybody
in this place and the reason why they're
all bagged up in body bags true
okay so where am I now why is absolutely
everything is closed off wonderful done
Oh another body how many bodies can
someone do an actual count of how many
bodies I've come across diary of the
affliction due to the recent outbreak
I've been requested to assist the
medical staff and their duties as
they're currently lacking personnel to
deal with it effectively and as a result
I suspect I will have to suspend my
regular activities the patients will be
introduced to me starting tomorrow only
seven of them have survived the
affliction and I fear some of them are
too weak to survive another week without
a sufficiently effective treatment we
must make haste in order to be able to
monitor their status I will be keeping a
log of sorts a diary if you will and
this will be its apprentice sign dr.
Rosenberg well this almost seems like
you care but I'm of the understanding
that over time you're gonna lose your
mind and then start not caring about
everybody and then you know being
generally a douchenozzle how things
water delicious water it replenishes
both health and the blue juice blue goo
all right so turn down the oxygen but
why why did I need oh it's turning up
the oxygen Oh
so up and down I can do it both but
what's the benefit I can remove the
flooring I didn't even think of that
that's kind of cool
it seems so solidly pace oh okay so I
bet I just need to change the flow of
oxygen okay is that all I can remove
that is okay so I bet if I turn it on
again it's gonna change the position of
it but I can no still going in both
places oh maybe I just need to go the
other way
there's nothing else well that's wrong
in hurt right
yep dad hurt can't go through there damn
it
okay then well ain't this a conundrum
and why can't I get out of here anymore
it wouldn't stop letting me out before
why all the sudden can I not get out now
okay that's a load of ass get down here
is that okay there we go thank you very
much okay so there's got to be some oh
there's another one I didn't see it cuz
it wasn't in the light and I'm a big
dumb do if you do and I don't know what
I'm doing great okay carrying on nor my
stupidity please please forgive me for
being such an idiot because I don't know
what
hello seems awfully dank in here I've
been smoking I can't oh there's a ladder
once again can't see [ __ ] I've tried
turn it up the brightness - on Mayan
because it's is so unbelievably dark
dork and if I turn off the brightness at
Prague into effect things on your end
but maybe I'll do it for the next
episode because I'm absolutely blasted
in the dark here hello high pressure
why is everything high pressure around
you I heard that what the [ __ ] was that
did I turn the pressure stop don't do
that don't do that don't did ah ok but
get out me way excuse me oh ok I thought
those actual thing to fire just what for
you then
so oh that's where I came from okay so
okay so now the fire would be out and I
will be able to traverse that okay and
where does this leave me why did it
suddenly lit on fire as soon as it
sounds let's don't do that stop doing
that you're doing that on purpose I know
you are cuz you're a dill weed hold good
oh is that outside is that tea outside
yes oh I didn't actually expect that to
open okay so I've got a choice here and
I'm gonna wait until the next episode to
get to it so thank you everybody so much
for watching I hope you're enjoying this
it's starting to get more soupy in here
which is a good thing
so we'll see more spoopy later on so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
there we go
[Music]